hello and welcome to the chicky science
show where in this video
i'm going to do my best to try and
explain what is an
mrna vaccine so firstly we'll talk about
what actually are vaccines and what
makes an effective vaccine
and then we'll look at what actually is
mrna and then lastly we'll put this into
some context
and look at the current mrna vaccines
that are being developed to try and
tackle
cavite19 so firstly then what is a
vaccine
well the purpose of a vaccine is to
provide active acquired immunity
to particular infectious diseases
therefore
if that person was infected by that same
infectious disease again in the future
they have some defense systems in place
to prevent or ameliorate
the effects of that infection so
vaccines not only differ in terms of
what infectious agents they're trying to
protect against
but they also vary in the way that they
are designed
for example they could be live
attenuated versions of that virus
they could be inactivated or killed
viruses
they could be virus-like particles or as
we'll see later in this video
they could be mrna-based now in addition
to
a successful vaccine being safe easy to
produce
and having long-lasting immunity in
broad terms for a vaccine to be
effective it needs two key components
firstly it requires antigens from the
target pathogen that our body can
develop
antibodies against and so these antigens
can be provided
by the vaccine itself or are generated
by the vaccine recipient
on receiving the vaccine and then
secondly it
needs an infection signal that alerts
our bodies and activates the host immune
system
to develop these different antibodies
and to create a memory against this
target pathogen so that if it comes
again
into our bodies we're ready to tackle it
so what then is an mrna vaccine well
to state the blatant obvious it's a
vaccine that contains
mrna but what does that actually mean
well
mrna stands for messenger ribonucleic
acid and
this mrna is an intermediate in gene
expression
that resides between dna and production
of a protein
so mrna contains the genetic codes that
the body can use to produce a protein so
in the context of an mrna vaccine
the vaccine contains mrna that contains
the information
to produce antigens for a specific
pathogen
and now mrna is a pretty temporary
molecule within our cells
and is vulnerable to degradation so how
do you get the mrna into our cells so
that our cells can produce
the antigen that the mrna encodes for
well one way this can be done is by
packaging
the mrna inside a lipid particle
that can cruise for our bodies and
make it into our cells so what is an
mrna vaccine in the context of cavite 19
well covered 19 is caused by the virus
sars cov2
and so to be able to have an effective
mrna vaccine against sars cough 2
we need that mrna to encode an antigen
of sars curve 2.
and so if we look here this is the
drawing i've done of sarskov
ii and you can see on its surface it has
these so-called spike proteins
that the forest uses to enter into our
cells
and it's been shown in previous cases of
coronavirus that only antibodies
directed against
the spike protein can neutralize the
virus and prevent
infection so unsurprisingly then the two
major mrna vaccines being produced
by modana and pfizer in collaboration
with
biointact are both developing mrna
vaccines
that contain the mrna that encodes
antigens of the spike protein
and so the vaccines aren't identical
between the two companies
the vaccine developed by biointec and
pfizer only contained information to
produce the receptor binding domain
of the spike protein nonetheless the
interesting thing
is that previously mrna vaccines have
not been licensed for human use
and there's actually a really
interesting article that goes into the
backgrounds
and history of the idea and conception
of using mrna
in vaccines and so i'll put the link for
that in the description however based on
other results gathered in mice
it does seem like these mrna vaccines
have potential and this is purported by
the announcements that were made earlier
this week for example with pfizer
so as this article states i hope we can
all conclude
that the world is in dire need of a safe
effective cavite 19 vaccine
and whether or not this comes from an
mrna vaccine or from one of the more
than 100 other vaccines that are
currently being
investigated i hope this video has given
you an
insight into what mrna vaccines are
and so with that i hope you've learned
something in this video and as always
thanks for listening